I went to UNI studied law at the end of
it I was like am I really going to spend
four or five years working up a
corporate company something I don't
enjoy so I just took a complete shift
ended up here in property there was no
way that if I invest this amount of
money in myself now in a year's time my
life's going to be the same and my
family everybody was like what have you
done what is it a scam so in the last
year you started with nothing right now
how much are you profit are you bringing
in each month 23 000 pounds this month
wow so I think one of my biggest lessons
has been get yourself in the room it's
not just what you know it's also who you
know so you brought in 50 Grand a lot of
people don't make that in a year
so how does it feel to be on winners on
a Wednesday absolutely surreal
um I remember when I first first came
when I went to the first training course
and you know we were looking at the
board of other people and when it was on
a Wednesday and I was like oh wow like
imagine being up there I really want to
be there and here we are so you have a
law degree talk to me about that yeah so
I went to UNI studied law I always kind
of thought I want to be a lawyer I want
to be a lawyer and
when it when they did it I mean I'm
dyslexic so doing a law degree would be
dyslexic with two kind of part and part
and at the end of it I was like am I
Really Gonna spend four or five years
working up a corporate company reading
papers for something I don't enjoy so I
just took a complete shift obviously
graduated from uni and went part-time
and then ended up here in property so
after you finished University then so
you studied laws you've got a degree in
law yeah and then you got a job in
marketing okay yeah so it was a complete
complete change it was covered obviously
when I finished uni
um and I got offered a job I started my
own small business on the side and I got
offered a job so I was working part-time
whilst doing that and it was just kind
of covering the bills giving me a bit of
saving kept me really busy through
lockdown
um but again it just wasn't exactly what
I wanted to be and I think from having
my own sort of small business I was very
much like I was my own boss in that
right which is something that I've
always wanted to be and always kind of
had that drive towards what was your
small business
um it actually started like the day I
graduated and it was it was just like a
social media business and I was just
customizing Jordan's trainers and just
selling them on okay yeah so it was a
really good business but it was um
seasonal it was a trend but that did
give me the money to join the academy
there we go so all kind of came from
Circle so what do you think about people
going to UNI because my attitude is I
think the university has got its place
absolutely but I think a lot of young
people just jump to UNI without actually
thinking about do I really want to be a
doctor do I really want to be a lawyer
and like yourself do they end up doing
something completely different and
nobody would really say oh that was a
waste of money or what did you do but
then but then you joined the academy and
I know that you're some of your family
your boyfriend for instance how did they
feel when you dropped 12g into the
academy yeah I mean I didn't really tell
anybody I don't going on the trading
course at the compound crash course and
I signed up then
and my family everybody was like what
have you done what is it a scam and I
was like no no like trust me trust me
it'll work I went on the the next train
and I thought you know what this is my
money this is my decision I'm not going
to tell anybody and I'm just gonna do it
anyway I made that decision
and I think because of how passionate
they saw I was after leaving those four
days you know you're so elated when you
leave those four days then they were
kind of like okay yeah I mean just just
keep trying keep trying just but keep a
job in mind kind of thing but yeah I
mean go into uni I think
I think it can be good if you know you
say you need it as a career as a doctor
Etc but that's kind of where a lot of my
why comes in and what I want to do and a
big thing for me is wanting to get you
know and speak to people when they're at
a young age maybe 15 16 and they're
about to make that kind of crucial
decision in their life do I go do I just
go to UNI because I need to go to UNI or
do I just go and get an apprenticeship
and then you end up in that nine to five
routine and you stuck I want to get into
schools and start to teach people you
know there's other ways of making money
there's other ways of you know having a
business and and taking care of yourself
and yes you might work really really
really hard but at the end of the day
it's for you yeah so that's that's kind
of where my why comes in in terms of
going to UNI Etc that's amazing and it's
not taught in the education system at
all you know they teach they teach lots
of stuff history art drama you can go to
Union learn Sports physiotherapy but
even if you go to UNI to learn about
business
um from what I've heard from people that
have been to University tournament
business the people that you're learning
from they're not actually business
experts and themselves they know that
they read the theory book but they're
not multi-millionaire business people
yeah so it's quite an interesting world
and people are very skeptical about
getting self-educated and going and
learning property or Investments or
people are very skeptical about that
yeah definitely I mean I think you've
massively massively opened up the market
I mean I have so many people coming up
to me now going oh can you just jump on
a quick call I've just been to the one
pound crash course or like like people
I've grown up with Germany and they're
all kind of my agency what I'm doing I
was at the gym the other day and I was
like oh yeah my parent went to the crash
course the other day because they follow
your property page so I think you've
just opened up that market for people
completely and that's a real good thing
it's possible amazing leaving a legacy
yeah and yes it's a business so talk to
me then about your very first property
deal and when did you make the decision
to go full time into property I mean I
actually went full time in property from
day one
um I moved back home with my parents I
was living up in Newcastle at the time
and I thought if I'm going to do it I'm
going all in and I'm going to make it
work so moved back home I was working
kind of part-time in a restaurant so
that's what they do as a trade and yeah
went full time into the business from
there really and it was it was tough you
know all of our money got into it and it
was I was completely new my first thing
was a joint venture and I went to rent
and that came two months in after the
training
um which was amazing that was on yeah
joint venture and then after that
it took me about four or five months
before
I actually started seeing the money come
in and it was a really slow start but
yeah that's definitely where where my
whole kind of story started and it was
that sort of thing of you know you turn
up for yourself every single day given
100 and I knew at the end of that day I
wasn't going to make any money yeah but
I kept doing it and kept doing it
because I had that undying belief in
myself that I am going to make this work
this is for me and this is what I want
so yeah I think that was a massive a
massive part of that and there's a
reason that the academy is a 12-month
program and not a one month program
because it can take time to start
getting results you say it took you sort
of four months before you started
actually seeing any money coming in yeah
during those four months I mean how much
money did you have once you joined the
academy and you went all in you went
back to your parents how much money did
you have to invest in property or to do
stuff with nothing at that point um I
was like I was working part-time and I
was literally I got an office in one of
the rooms at home was working every
single day and I'd go and do like
part-time work at the restaurant so just
maybe a couple hundred pounds here and
there but I was like in my overdraft and
normally I've been quite good with money
before that so it was a complete shift
so my first deal that came on a joint
venture I borrowed the money to do my
side of the joint venture and then
obviously paid that back so that first
deal was no money in of my own so talk
to me through that first deal then how
was it structured how did you find it
what happened I was on the four day
training the rent to rent and
and I was speaking to Tyrone and Chantel
and they said oh we found a deal in
Liverpool and we've been speaking kind
of briefly beforehand and it was at the
Academy dinner
we kind of walked past each other
anywhere and I went are you tbck and
they're like yeah you Adriana anyway we
sat down really really got on and they
said look we've got a deal do you want a
joint venture on it you manage it
Etc and that was kind of how the first
deal came about it was really really
exciting but that wouldn't have happened
had we not been in that room and had we
not been at that dinner yeah so I think
one of my biggest lessons has been get
yourself in the room be in the room and
speak to everybody and now you're like
constantly all over it yeah events the
dinners on The Mastermind calls sharing
speaking participate because it's not
just I mean it's not just what you know
it's also who you know and I think
that's one of the reasons people say
like oh man you paid 12 grand for a
course it's like it's a course
mentorship Community Network oh 100 I
mean my first I mean my social media was
has been a massive thing for me and
obviously getting out there and getting
connections but a lot of that social
media people comes from being at the
events and being at the training oh I
know you I know you and that builds you
up you almost didn't get that sense of
credibility and then you know your first
deal start to sell which it's not just
about being in the room it's about
making sure that you are good at what
you do and what you put out to the world
is absolutely top tier because it's
competitive and I think that's one thing
that I really really really drill down
into to make sure that the deals and the
properties I'm putting out are the
absolute best and that my customer
service and you know my relationship
with my investors has been absolutely
top tier throughout so you've done joint
ventures what other strategies have you
done within property since joining the
academy so joint ventures I've done rent
to rent and also deal selling nice
service accommodation service
accommodation yeah so rent service
accommodation and how long have you been
in the academy now it's coming up a year
now coming up a year so in the last year
you started with nothing yeah right now
how much if you don't mind me asking on
an average month are you making are you
generating how much are you profiting in
each month so to be fair this has just
been my biggest month from yesterday
um including the rent to rent 23 000
pounds this month wow
incredible yeah incredible so and that's
a combination of deal sourcing on rental
routes yeah definitely what's the
breakdown of that income where's that
coming from yeah so rent to rent is
around about average 3K a month and
that's across three properties
um and then the rest of the money's deal
selling so you're making 3K every month
from your rent to rent which is kind of
paying your bills yeah you know it's
like a full-time salary basically and
how systemized is that with the rent to
rent um I mean I do self-manage but I
have my channel management teams in
place everything's simple I mean one
property's got a three month on booking
at the minute so it's quite hands-off
yeah you obviously have to put the work
in you can't become stagnant on your
business it's just like any company you
know if you want to grow you have to be
there being Innovative and putting the
work in but as a whole I spend a lot
more of my time on my deal so inside of
things because that's my main Money
Maker but also
um yeah so I made obviously the 23 000
pound from that but I've also made 25
000 this month on project management
oh my goodness yeah which which starts
next month but the money's been made so
you brought in 50 Grand this month yeah
how does it feel to be making that kind
of money absolutely incredible amazing
um it's it's really strange because I
think sometimes when you work work at
work and you keep pushing you almost
forget to look back
and then you kind of sit back and think
oh wow and for me this all happened in
maybe the last four or five months of my
Academy so it kind of went from nothing
to then full steam ahead and then you
know in the last month
honestly I mean that a lot of people
don't make that in a year it's insane I
think definitely you know working with
other people it's been a massive part of
it you've done incredibly well thank you
do you pinch yourself sometimes yeah
yeah like now this is one of the moments
yeah yeah what would you say is the
biggest difference between people that
succeed and people that that don't oh
never give up never ever ever give up I
strongly think that everybody can
achieve success everybody can achieve
success but what separates you is that
how hard are you prepared to work and
how many problems are you prepared to
deal with because I mean I've come up
against brick wall brick wall brick wall
over and over again and I think it was
actually after the eviction because
after that happened I was like I've not
really got much going on
and it was over the summer and I
remember I sat down with my mum and I
was like I don't know if I'm gonna need
to get a job and I was like just give me
another month just give me another
another month let me let me see if if
this works
and I pushed past that last hurdle and
things happened now I think some people
at that point probably would have been
put off a few months before you know
when it's not working and you're working
from 7am to 11 P.M every single night
without fail
and I think that's the biggest
difference between failing and
succeeding yeah and unlike a job where
you're trading your time for money with
business you're getting paid for your
value oh yeah and it can take a few
months before you've got the skills and
yeah so to begin with you might be
working and you're not getting paid yeah
and it's like whoa but when you persist
and you keep getting the skills and you
keep getting better that's when you can
start having 50 Grand months exactly
exactly it's it's the same thing as what
Jim Rowan says in it is it just your
value to the marketplace how much do you
bring yeah I take that on board every
single day so when I bring investors on
board they know that they're going to
get every single thing they need from me
so it's you know negotiating the best
deals guiding them through giving them a
hand where they need helping them with
the setup with the staging providing
packs to my investors everything you
need to put in this rent to rent you
know they get the full process and I
think I think I probably learned that
from being young and working in a
restaurant from being 14 and having to
communicate with people all the time and
everything is about how well can you
communicate how many layers of trust can
you build
and how much value can you add to that
person which ultimately means they're
going to want to keep you know doing
repeat business with you Word of Mouth
marketing that's been massive for me I
get phone calls every day
hi Adriana um I've just been recommended
you know to come and secure a deal from
yourself and move forward and it's Word
of Mouth which has been massive yeah and
that's the thing isn't it it's momentum
it builds when you when you start
packages and selling deals assuming you
do a good job people want to the same
investors will buy from you again and
again and again your first deal is your
hardest interesting what you mentioned
about a white dress well sometimes when
I'm out for dinner I'll see the
waitresses busy Restaurant They're
rushing around and I know they've got
like a 10 hour shift and I'm thinking
they work just as hard as I work yet
they'll make 100 pounds in a day and
I'll make 100 Grand in a day some days
like what's going on yeah it's crazy but
luckily I was smart enough to switch
that to business yeah I've always been
business my parents have been
entrepreneurs so I've always
had a businessman but I've realized you
know you've got to work on things and
not in it yeah so it's getting to the
point of now moving forward how do we
start to systemize the companies I'm
absolutely still massively going to be
involved but you know it's bringing
another sources bringing in other people
who can work in the business give me
more time to grow the brand connect with
new investors Network and really make
sure that everything goes smoothly the
only struggle with that is you know how
do you release control because I am very
very particular in terms of what deals I
put out to my investors yeah and things
like well that's the next part of the
academy accelerate coaching performance
program which is all about scaling and
you know and you're about nine ten
months in so that that's now time to
time to scale time to bring on staff how
much do you charge them on average for
like a project management what would I
what would an average project management
fee give you yes it's 10 of the build
cost right so a lot at the minute what
we're doing is doing um full Cash Out
deals for our investors I mean the last
two that have gone this month are
investors are pulling out around 40 50
000 pounds on these deals amazing yeah
yeah so then what we do is we know we
secure the deal from them they've
obviously built that relationship we
then obviously offer the project
management because a lot of our
investors want the hands off you know
we've got our really strong build team
in the area who understand everything to
do with HMO so we can kind of guide our
investors all the way through the
process but we've also got Brokers we've
got Architects so we literally give the
full package to our investors yeah and I
think yeah they're paying 10 it's
nothing well it is nothing exactly the
refurb is 50 Grand yeah they're going to
pay an extra five grand but if they do
it themselves then they'd probably end
up spending 80 grand I don't know
exactly exactly you know you've got the
trusted people in the area because a lot
of our investors maybe they're from down
south and not in the area they're not
going to have access to the people that
we do and yeah like you said once once
they're recycling their money once they
know they're getting a good deal from us
they want to go again and again and
again which is just yeah how many deals
have you sold
um about 40 about 40 deals yeah and
you're charging sometimes project
management fees yeah much on average
might you put a charge for it for a yeah
so an average deal is about three
thousand pounds about three grand yeah
that's a big money owner for you but at
the same time talk to me about why
would people pay thousands of pounds for
you to find a deal when they could find
themselves and secondly how are you
finding these investors why would people
pay that money is you know you're
getting a deal from a trusted Source now
I understand there's a lot of deals
selling that goes on um but I think with
my investors why why it's worked so well
is that it's not just so there's your
deal thank you it's here's my deal
here's a really really in-depth
investors pack please let's go over the
numbers together you know they're
getting all the information they could
possibly need to really see the value in
this deal a lot of the time I either get
people who was just starting out because
they just need a deal I mean once you've
got a deal under your belt you can you
know then you've got that bit of
credibility
um and I think as well with my
connections I'm able to secure these
really good deals because of the
networks I've built up so sometimes
people think I don't want to just bang
my head against a rope wall and get a
load of nose I just want to get on the
ladder and get started and then secondly
finding investors one massive thing has
been my social media because you know my
face is all over I'm there and I'm
speaking to people so people know who I
am and the academy that's been huge and
get up on stage and speaking again just
getting myself out there in the
community
and also word of mouth I remember when I
started out it was like the standard
yeah go to Facebook go on all the
different pages on Facebook and they're
not warm leads so you have to work a lot
harder to get that money now people come
to me you know I've got my mailing list
people sign up to that they get deal
sent out every week but we're also doing
a lot more bespoke invested now so
really tailoring our investors to what
exactly are you guys looking for and
give me a breakdown of your criteria and
okay we've got then our time to provide
that for you and then they know that
that's deals exclusive to them they get
first access and it just kind of gives
people that security that I'm definitely
going to get the deal that I'm exactly
looking for yeah what is it that drives
you then because to make the kind of
money that you're making yes you've got
a great business model and you've
invested in yourself and you've got the
skills the support Community but what is
it that drives you to keep going every
day yeah that I mean
at this point
when I look back at everything that I've
put in how far I've come I've always
known it was inside me to be an
entrepreneur to be a businesswoman it's
always been in me I mean I've never been
afraid of hard work
and now to see it all taking place and
see it happening communicating with
people make meaning that I can get
someone off the ground in their property
business or I can help someone else in
their property business that's a massive
part of it and again the bigger picture
is I want to get to a point where I'm
leaving a legacy you know I can be out
there I can be helping people young
people how can they change their life
how can they take things to the next
level and that's what drives me I think
as well when you're not just thinking
about the money when you're thinking
about actually providing a good service
then the Money Follows yeah Albert
Einstein says that Albert Einstein says
don't try and be successful try and be
valuable yeah because the success will
always follow the value
biggest tips then for getting into
property for someone that wants to do
what you're doing emulate your success
deal sourcing rent to rent what were
your biggest tips your reputation very
hard to build very easy to lose focus on
your reputation you know when when
you're sending out a deal when you're
bringing a deal make sure that you have
got every little bit of information you
can get your hands on and you present
that really clearly to your investor
that's that's massive that is that is
huge because as soon as you just start
sending things out getting desperate and
inflating numbers your reputation is
shut and it's really hard to come back
from especially when it's a competitive
market and yeah just keep pushing keep
going keep working get the training get
the training because
it it doesn't fail do you know what I
mean if you're prepared to implement
what's been taught why reinvent the
wheel what happened at the deal selling
masterclass or what was your experience
at the deal selling masterclass so yeah
that was the very first train I remember
I turned up and it was the four days and
I was just like wow this is absolutely
amazing you know I was like I need to be
in this room and I said oh yeah
I'll just I'll be able to do it I'll be
able to get these deals and you know I
spent a bit more time over the next few
days and I was speaking to all these
people and obviously we're speaking
about the academy and every single
person I went to in the room I was like
just can you just give me some advice
what do you think and he went changes
your life it really does change your
life and yeah that's that's when I then
made the decision it was the last day
before the dinner I decided to make the
decision I thought there is no way that
if I invest this amount of money in
myself now in a year's time my life's
going to be the same yeah
and I think you've got to have a level
of self-belief to do that you know when
you when you're the only person that
kind of thinks that you've you've got to
have a level of self belief and again
you guys you know when you take people
out and you assess them and you decide
are they a good fit for the Academy
having that reassurance of someone
saying yeah you know I think I think I
think you're going to be a really good
fit for it on top of my sort of
self-belief and drive I was just kind of
like right I'm gonna do it I've got the
money there now um I was 22 at the time
and I thought you know what if I wait a
few more years who knows what could
happen and I might I might not be able
to do it or some I might be in a
different place but I've been a
different job if I do this now and by 23
I'll be loving it and here we are yeah
and as well like on the DLC masterclass
I mean usually I'll sell deals from
stage oh yeah and I'll be there saying
who's got deals and I'll be bringing up
my investors and selling them closing
and you can't see that and then just go
okay cool anyway back to work
oh yeah it changed your perspective
massively I think I remember I was
texting I was like I can't sleep again
tonight just too excited to get back
like I just I couldn't switch off from
it yeah everything you were saying like
every five minutes I was just trying to
go and find another deal do something I
might not have been getting it right but
I was doing it and I was taking action
and that is what started it all and to
see you be on stage and thinking how's
he just got someone to send him three
grand when they've not even seen the
deal I was like I need to do that I need
to build that up and one one of the
biggest things again was you suddenly
leads it's the reputation I mean you've
got that trust so that is what I LED
from day one build up your reputation
massively what are your proudest
achievements then in property I think
there's been a few to be honest
um
obviously the money that I've been I've
been able to make
um in the reputation I've been able to
build
um speaking on stage you know when you
called me up last week to like come out
and talk on the stage that was just such
a
amazing experience that you know you've
trusted me to go up on there and deliver
to a room with people my experience so
far and then obviously all the people
that come up afterwards and the messages
of that you're inspiring people like
that's just to me is just amazing yeah
that's that's been my experience and
definitely when when you said I was
going to change millions of people's of
lives in the world yeah well because a
lot of this is the thing a lot of people
when they become successful like
yourself they hide away and they think
oh I'm making lots of money now the
amount of people you know this you're on
the academy that have become you know
making 10 grand 20 grand a month and
then I say oh come on winners on a
Wednesday and they go oh I don't want to
come on Wednesday because then everybody
will start doing what I'm doing in my
area and I don't want to create
competition and it's like what number
one that's completely selfish but number
two it's the opposite collaboration come
and share the Story come on stage come
on winners on Wednesday and yes you're
going to inspire people you're going to
help people but also people are going to
reach out you're going to be able to
build businesses grow together and I
think thinking collaboratively is a lot
more powerful than thinking
competitively yeah I think success
breeds success you know I mean like now
I'm doing a lot where I'm working the
co-sources and I'm helping them to kind
of you know find good deals because
ultimately the better they can package
up a deal
the easier it is for me to say yes that
looks good send that out to my investor
that's a deal sold yeah and obviously
the more deals we have Yeah the more
investors and that's what the bigger the
academy grows the academic because they
want more people to do business
I love I love working with people who
have been in the academy because
about that same level of training that I
do yeah so they're going to operate
around the same kind of standards as
well which has been massive talk to me
about the eviction
yeah the eviction wow what an experience
that is probably what kick-started My
Success after the fact
but in itself it was just amazing it was
being in that environment around all
these amazing amazing people you know
everybody in there so so hard working so
I kind of thrived in that environment
you know every single challenge was a
completely different skill set that I
then grew on and grew on and grew under
my confidence built I mean it's quite
funny really for some reason I was a
little bit scared of rent to rent and
even when I got to the eviction I'd kind
of like put off making the calls and I
don't know why because I'm so confident
to ring up a landlord or estate agent
say oh I'm a cash buyer you know I'll
buy this house hundred thousand pound
yeah that's fine don't worry and then
for some reason when it came to um
making the calls for rent to rent I just
I almost froze I was like oh what if I
say something wrong what if they asked
me for this and anyway I went on the
eviction and I had no choice I had to
make the calls and I had to do it so
that was a massive massive thing for me
even the last challenge I mean to say
how far I got which is just absolutely
surreal the last challenge even the
raising Finance although it didn't pull
off again I just learned so much yeah
yeah
um also watching back the eviction you
were pretty brutally evicted yeah yeah
and you do a tears yeah there was lots
of Tears did that make you stronger yeah
massively and I think everybody that got
through to the final absolutely deserved
to be there I mean that that was the
challenge and yes it was really
emotional and yes it was a really tough
challenge
but had that not have happened maybe I
wouldn't have been so hungry to really
achieve this success and yeah I think
you know from leaving that it was maybe
a month after that that I then got my
first my my very own first rent to rent
and it was a lot of negotiating but it
was a property that I fully refurbed and
I you know I've got new floor in there I
painted it I decorated it
and I did it all myself so I was in
there and I was sleeping on a mattress
for three weeks on the floor and I
didn't have any hot water and I was
grafting but I was documenting it so
then people were seeing Oh you know
she's really serious about what she's
doing like look what she's prepared to
do you know to kind of get her deal over
the line and again that just built up
built up my network Built My credibility
but yeah that all stemmed from the
eviction of you know when we were
Furnishing the house we slept on the
floor We Didn't Start we worked till
four or five o'clock in the morning
every single day so that it was just a
massive like okay
go time if you're advising yourself from
say a year or two ago because you're now
only how old 23 23. if you're advising
your 21 year old self who's working
part-time marketing waitressing whatever
whatever what would you say
have more confidence in yourself
definitely because I've always known I
could be this person but it was kind of
there was always something holding me
back I've taken the next steps and so
it's just a case of yeah get up and go
make it work yeah and how important do
you think environment is because it's
something I bang on about a lot and not
just knowledge not just network not just
having mentoring but actually being in
an environment where you're around other
people winning other people doing deals
what do you think about that oh it's
been huge it's been massive I mean it's
an example the weekly calls you know at
the start when you're hearing every
single person week on week getting these
amazing results it's you're okay I need
to wake up I can do this why can't I do
this um
environment's been everything you know
you come down to the network and donors
and we're up till three o'clock in the
morning just chatting and there's
business done and there's you know you
learn so much from other people and you
then you jump on Zoom calls with
somebody else and they say oh maybe try
this in your business or oh what advice
would you give me here and constantly
you're exchanging knowledge and like now
my phone blows up all the time or if
I've ever got a problem I'll send you
know voice notes to five six different
people and I'll get a response from
every single person and I think that's
just Priceless yeah yeah and also
success buddies but also mentors like
anytime you want you can get an Mentor
or you can chat to people of
millionaires exactly like where could
you get that normally and especially
such a variety like you've all you know
everybody every single Mentor
specializes in their own area yeah so
you know that you get that one-on-one
help and where else and what other
training can you get that you know you
might just have one Mentor for example
they don't have all the answers to every
question yeah having such a wide variety
again has been huge because you never
you're never alone what's snakes for
Adriana then what's your 2023 plan yes
so project managements are obviously
starting next month and we're getting a
lot more deals coming in now obviously
the investors let's just grow in so it's
ensuring that we can really build up the
company build up the brand and make sure
that we're really hitting them targets
and then yeah it's buy-in So within the
next four months going to be buying my
own project start yeah I know you've got
that going through now you've got
properties in in the pipeline so yeah
there's Potentials in the pipeline now
um and obviously what's a project money
project management money lands then
that's going to be then used to secure
the deals and you know using our
bridging companies that we already work
with and then get underway to the
refurbatory finance well massive well
done Adriana I can't believe how much
you've achieved at the age of War and in
the time frame that you've done it and
I'm really excited to see you continuing
to go from strength to strength thank
you so much
[Music]
thank you